[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
das fruchteis hat euch ja mal ich schon
ziemlich gut gefallen heute geht es noch
eine zweite variante ein schokoladeneis
auch blitzschnell gemacht ohne
eismaschine mit nur wenigen zutaten
vegan glutenfrei ohne zucker also ich
glaube mehr braucht man zur diese meist
gar nicht sagen dafür nämlich 200 gramm
avocados 300 gramm reife bananen 50
gramm kakaopulver ohne zucker natürlich
100 gramm kokosmilch oder eine andere
milch ich habe ich etwas will extrakt
und schokoladen streuseln bei der
avocado wirklich darauf achten dass sie
schon reif ist also ich gucke dann noch
immer das sehr weich ist und hier oben
könnt ihr diesen knopf damals wegnehmen
und dann ist er da drinnen schöngrün
wenn sie braun ist ist sie praktisch ein
bisschen zu reichen überreif da würde
ich dann die finger weglassen
aber ansonsten einfach wirklich schön
eine weiche avocado nehmen die hätten
jetzt noch bisschen weicher sein dürfen
aber es ist okay bei den bananen auch
gerne darauf achten dass sie sehr reif
sind und da habe ich jetzt sogar schon
gemacht ich habe sie vorbereitet und
zwar einfach geschält und eingefroren so
hatte ich schon mal eine kalte banane
und im prinzip nehmt ihr jetzt einfach
eure schüssel liegt praktisch die
bananen ab als auch die 300 gramm
die frühere ich wieder ein und packte
dann auch in der schüssel das nächste
mal oder für smoothies zum beispiel dann
habe ich immer aber namen auf vorrat wie
einfach tief gefrorene früchte
es sind einfach exakt 300,0 wie ich
jetzt wohl nur nur betonen es ist
gesprungen
das war der windstoß und mit reifen
bananen meine ich auch wirklich super
reifer als die dürfen schon so aussehen
die werden praktisch geschält
geschnitten eingefroren und dann habt
ihr die wirklich immer schön auf vorrat
das kann ich hier noch die avocado dazu
abwägen das ist wirklich immer schön
dass geschälte gewicht dann habt ihr
auch jedes mal das eis in der gleichen
qualität und eben mit dem gleichen
geschmack auch die ella wollte auch mit
hilfen in die hände wäscht kannst du mit
helfen
wow so ein einfaches und ich habe gleich
drei helferinnen für die cremigkeit
genau die avocado das ist eine gute
frage samira die avocado kommt rein für
die cremigkeit damit das eis das
schmeckt man nicht raus das ist
praktisch der ersatz für eier und für
sahne
was man eben normalerweise in einer hart
da nehmen wir jetzt hier eben die
avocado gut
es darf die ela bisschen helfen weil er
schon beim fruchteis geholfen habt kommt
darüber mit einem hocker vorsicht kamera
ja wir machen schokostreusel rein und
ich habe es jetzt hier so gemacht dass
ich den multi zerkleinerer war also
meine mixa einfach eingefroren habe dann
ist das schon ganz schwarz sonst hauen
die bananen wieder aufkommt sie das mal
ganz kurz darüber denn sonst kannst du
ja gar nicht dran
rechtlich gibt es jetzt hier oben kurz
rein weil er laufe die hier ist glaube
ich bis hin zu schwer und du darfst
jetzt aber wandel extractor zu gehen
übertreibt michaela man muss immer
wirklich nur wenig nehmen nur einen
teelöffel oder sogar noch weniger
das weiß man dass lincoln 200 nicht aber
so 05 kakaopulver also back cacau
kokosmilch und wenn ihr sagt ihr mit den
geschmack von kokosmilch nicht könnt ihr
natürlich auch normale menschen oder
etwas crème fraiche aus sahne aber ihr
seht auch bei diesem rezept kommt
praktisch kein industriezucker mit
reinen sondern wir nutzen die banane als
führungskraft ein neues rezept und jetzt
mixen
[Musik]
wo bleibt denn da die ferne ist okay das
ist okay ich komme damit klar
also wir probleme praktisch mal war das
mal lasst mich mal kurz vor testen denn
ich erhöhe die bananen menge denn den
kindern wird zu wenig süß sein
ich nehme vielmehr banane okay ich habe
ziemlich viel kv rein das schmeckt jetzt
gerade noch ein bisschen herz das
schmeckt ja einfach aber ich schreibe
euch gleich die geänderte menge eben in
den lockt vor allem ist es bei sony
also wenn es ihr müsst so problemlos
süßer schmecken wenn es gefroren ist
verliert sich die süße noch bisschen
mehr bananen wollte mal probieren mädels
und dann probiert er einfach gleich
nochmal nach dem einfrieren ja also mit
gibt es da klettert das war eine derbe
aber auch sauber und es kommen noch die
schokostückchen also nochmal wissen
bananen
nummer zwei und das ist noch mal 200
gramm drauf
ok mädels hörstel dorf zu lassen
so bin nicht gut vor dem alter
und ich glaube wenn das gleich einfriert
mitteln schokostreuseln als ich jetzt
kurz abkratzen
was ist aber mit schokostreusel
probieren oder ihr seid vielleicht
marsch katzen so so
[Musik]
so feinschmecker die kinder sind
geschmäcker ich höre jetzt hier auch
noch die schokostreusel ein und dann
freaks einfährt wird zwei stunden und
früher einfach ab und zu durch das ist
praktisch der partie wo ihr die
eismaschine ersetzt und praktisch selber
mal alle 30 minuten rühren müsste damit
es schön cremig wird aber wir nehmen
eine flache schale dann wird jetzt auch
schnell nach
[Musik]
so ein kind ist okay zwei kinder auch
bei drei kindern ist schon eine
geduldsprobe
aber bleibt chilis bleibt locker
sie dankt er seine beschäftigung und
gleichen leckeres eis mit zusatzjoker
die kinder sind wirklich die mama auch
glücklich
seid ihr bereit für schokolade ist also
nicht ganz gefroren aber ich finde es
jetzt gar nicht so schlimm ist doch
nicht so kalt manchmal so nein das ist
jetzt noch softeis also ich hatte es
auch nur eine stunde im gefragt wieso
heißt so wer am schnellsten ist bekommt
das eis zuerst eine ruhige kinder brave
kinder geduldige kinder war es noch ein
ruhiges kind
wer möchte einen schoko eis ist ruhiges
kind kann probiert da es keine straßen
das sind streusel drin im eis drin
lexmark und probiert mal banane
schokolade
was meint ihr also für mich passt der
süße perfekt dank für die kinder auch
das ist inhalt natürlich süßes ist es
gewohnt aber ich will jetzt auch einfach
keinen zucker dazugeben
oder noch mal ein anderes süßungsmittel
von daher passt es perfekt ihr könnt
euch noch ein paar streusel drauf machen
ich wünsche euch viel spaß beim
nachmachen frühem ein einziger ein
dann kann morath auch noch was essen und
das restliche team
und dann wünsche ich euch viel spaß beim
nachmachen und bis zum nächsten mal
und schreibt mir gerne wenn ihr weitere
sollte schnelle rezepte und einfache
rezepte sehen wollten
fußball ist ja heute gibt es eine mini
portionen eis das reicht
[Musik]
rabea wir gehen raus zum stumpfen waffen
willst du gehen ja dann mag man jetzt
frag mal in die kamera hat er hört dich
sag mal stimming
[Musik]
dann frag mal in die kamera sagen wir
hier strom waffe dürfen will ich besuche
ich glaube da hört dich dann wenn du in
die kamera spricht hier guckt beim
schreiben
geht doch